an arab mystery has always surrounded
nevada's area 51 base for years the u.s
military denied that it even existed but
it's been there since 1955 hidden behind
cryptic nicknames now new secrets about
the base being made public including for
the first time its real name george
knapp of the eight news now i team has
the story
area 51 is in one sense a living
breathing contradiction that is the
world's best known secret base it's
inspired books tv shows even major
motion pictures welcome to area 51 but
was it ever truly a secret air 51 was
never secret you know the existence of
it it's just who was out there and what
they were doing long time cia technician
t.d barnes has probably done more than
anyone to lift the bale of secrecy from
area 51. he's the head of the
roadrunners a group of former area 51
employees who came out into the open
more than a decade ago to talk about the
work they did in the nevada desert
barnes took things much further nudging
the cia to declassify photos and
documents about the base things even the
cia didn't seem to know including the
base's real name station d was the cia's
original name for area 51. it's right
there in the title of barnes new
definitive history of the place they had
all kind of documents in there
identified as station d wow and it just
has avoided that the public hasn't seen
that until right now they've never seen
it and the uh but even when i went back
to historians you get more they said
we've never heard of that in his book
barnes outlines the astonishing array of
names nicknames and code names used for
the base since it was first chosen by
the cia
back in 1955 as the perfect spot to
secretly test and fly the highly
classified u-2 spy plane groom blake is
the location so that's always been used
cia employees initially called it
watertown or the watertown strip named
for the hometown of the cia director at
the time the designation area 51 started
in 1958 when the cia needed to annex
land from the nearby atomic testing
range in order to develop the a12
blackbird sometime in the 60s the 51
disappeared from maps and the military
started pretending there wasn't a base
out there at all even though russian spy
planes knew it was there lockheed used
the name paradise ranch a cruel joke to
lure workers out to the desert it was
anything but paradise paradise ranch
became just the ranch then red square or
the box which referred to the no-fly
zone around the base several other names
popped up over the decades yuletide
saint elsewhere home plate homey airport
and the site along with many other
variations including what might be the
best of the bunch dreamland taken from a
tower call sign the cia used cover
stories basically lies to disguise what
went on at groom lake in the beginning
it was supposedly a nasa weather station
then an atomic energy research facility
but the whole time the cia was
developing the world's most advanced
espionage platforms technology that
helped the us win the cold war in the
70s when cia misdeeds caught the
attention of congress and two presidents
it suddenly dawned on washington that
the cia was forbidden from operating
inside the u.s station d was shut down
and control transferred to the u.s air
force in the mid 80s when the air force
seized 89 thousand acres of public land
around groomed lake public attention was
aroused at the end of the 80s it
exploded because of a certain wild story
the one that made the base world famous
which barnes also covers in his new book
when the word got out that there's
something going on area 51 and that cia
was involved for 20 years that no one
knew about
they said what were they doing for 20
years out there and that's when the ufo
thing started ufos eh at area 51 kind of
rings a bell actually nine
flying saucers george knapp 8 news now